Recognizing images in other apps with Seeing
AI.
So far, we have seen the different channels
which allow you to get different types of
information about the world around you.
However, sometimes you want to get that kind
of information about photos that already exist,
maybe in your camera roll, but also within
another apps, like Twitter or WhatsApp or
Mail.
With Seeing AI, you can actually use the same
technology to recognize those photos too.
Whenever you come across an image where you
need a description off, you use the app’s
share feature.
Not because you want to share it, but because
at the bottom of that share pane, there are
different actions like copy and print.
And there is also an action called “Recognize
with Seeing AI”.
So, when you select that, you will get the
same descriptions that you’ve seen with
other channels on that photo that came from
Twitter or WhatsApp.
Now, that’s really cool because sometimes
you’ll get an invitation in an email which
is just an image instead of the actual text.
Or maybe you’re on twitter and there is
a funny photo that everybody is commenting
on.
So now, with this feature, you can participate
in those too.
So here, I have the twitter app with a tweet
from my colleague Meher open.
Let’s see what it says.
> So many chores to do today.
> Landscape, image
> Double tap to view full size image
So clearly that’s a comment about this image.
But wouldn’t it be great if I could know
what’s inside this image.
That’s what we can do with Seeing AI.
So let’s open up the image.
> Landscape, image
> Double tap and hold for more actions
Add let’s bring up those actions
> Enable airdrop sharing.
Button
And across the bottom here, we have different
actions to perform on the image.
> Cancel
> Delete photo, Save photo, button
> Open in Safari, button
> Recognize with Seeing AI, button
That’s the one we want
> Processing
> Text
> Gotta drop off my laundry and pick up my
bone
> Scene: A dog sitting on the seat of a car
Hah, funny
Microsoft logo appears